plus de 1000 personnes à versailles 300
à saint germain en laye à rambouillet
les catholiques yvelinois étaient
mobilisés ce dimanche devant les lieux
de culte des rassemblements de déclarer
en préfecture comme ici devant sainte
bernadette à rambouillet ils demandent
le retour de la messe
très concrètement ce qu'on demande c'est
que il ya vraiment ce principe de
laïcité qui soit reconnue avec une
véritable séparation entre l'église et
l'état et de laisser l'église organisé
en fait les règles sanitaires à
l'intérieur de ses propres s'élèvent à
sion pour le moment les églises sont
ouvertes et les fidèles peuvent s'y
recueillir individuellement mais pour
les catholiques cela ne suffit pas la
messe doit être célébrée ya deux
dimensions dans la baisse
la première c'est la dimension du
rassemblement voilà le catholicisme est
une religion qu'on ne pratique pas seuls
et pas chez soi donc pas seulement et
puis la deuxième dimension c'est que la
messe est une action
il se passe quelque chose c'est ce qu'on
appelle une liturgie
voilà donc la de cet acte religieux n'a
plus lieu
et ça c'est embêtant pas là mais c'est
donc pour les chrétiens essentiel c'est
un moment qui permet aux fidèles de
s'unir autour de la foi qu'en tournée
catholique
on croit en jésus et dans la messe me
hsu pour nous voilà pourquoi c'est
important
c'est comme si on parlait de quelqu'un
et qu'on ne voyait jamais ne pas avoir
de metz
c'est lundi 16 novembre le ministre de
l'intérieur gerra darmana a reçu les
représentants des cultes pour échanger
sur les évolutions possibles des
pratiques de la religion incompatible
avec les règles sanitaires